This episode is supported by 23andMe
UN expects by 2050
3.2 million people will be 100 years old and over
Compared with 316,000 in 2011
If so, what can you do to become one of them
Elite centenarian club
How can you live for 100 years?
There are clear steps
Such as stopping eating outside the home
Those who are 65 are cooking five times a week
They have a 45% chance of living for centuries
The vegetarian person has less chance
For early death at 12%
If you continue to eat meat
Keep away from cold meats
Processed meat such as sausage, bacon, cold meat
Linked to a high rate of infection
Death from cancer and heart disease
Less clear, you can win an Academy Award
Winners, on average
They live four years more than the losers
Even the Nobel Prize
May help to live
One to two years more
Twenty province in the United States with lots of life benefits
At an average altitude of 5,967 feet above the sea
In Japan, women live to age 87 on average, and men for 80
Compared to the United States
82 for women and 77 for men respectively
So, like the Japanese
You should start by consuming green tea and fish
A scientific study of 40500 Japanese people
I proved that those who drink five cups of green tea a day
They have a lower chance of dying from heart disease
And who diet Omega 3 of the fish
Living 2.2 years increase
WHO advises
Exercise for at least 150 minutes per week
Increases your chances of living for 4 more years
You may be swimming or even shopping
A Taiwanese study found that those who shop daily
Even if they did not buy anything
Reduces the chance of their death by 23% to 28%
As for sleep, study is lengthy
I found that men slept for at least 6 hours
They have a greater chance of four times dying
Resulted from 14 years of study
It is important to be a realistic person
Literally !
German study found
Those who exaggerate the happiness of their future
They have a great chance to die compared
Of those who expect a dark future
The Spaniards live at a normal rate
Two and a half more than
Americans are at a natural rate
The researchers assume that
Maximizing the family increases the length of life
A Polish study found that the daughters of girls
They live 74 weeks more than normal
From the fathers of children
And if you are a woman
Be more like Beyonce and wish for twins
A new study has revealed that twins have twins
Evolution may be adaptation
Healthy mothers pass weakness
Gene once
Twins are known to live longer
And when planning comes to your life
Married, Danish study for gay men
I found that those who marry
They have a lower mortality rate
But . Do not marry a person
Another study of 1700 adult married found that
Whenever the couple quarrels
Their health
Do not force to retire
He found the Harvard longevity project
Those who have a satisfactory job
They continued to work until the age of 70 years
I have lived for many years
And pet breeding
A study showed that those who breed for dogs and cats
They lived for years more than those who do not pet pets
Even if you have not lived a healthy life yet
It is not too late to start a healthy life
The study of JET
Starting a healthy habit is like eating well
Doing exercises, thinking,
Encourage friends and family
It can increase the length of telomeres
The layer at the end of the chromosomes
Which wear out over time
If so, start doing these tips
And start preparing to live for 100 years
Special thanks to 23andMe for sponsoring this video.
If you've ever wanted to understand your own DNA
and see where regions of the world
your ancestors come from,
Egypt, how your DNA influences
physical hits and health,
then check out: [shows on screen]
We've tried it ourselves,
and found out that Greg has a lot of Neanderthan DNA
while Mitch found out why he likes pizza so much.
All you have to do is spit in a tube, and they'll
analyze your 23 pairs of chromosomes.
(Which is where the name comes from.)
agian, head to
"23andMe.com/asap"
To learn more about yourself, now.
You can also check out our second video,
"Where do people live the longest"
By clicking the screen, or using the link in the description.